hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and I can't
believe that Black Clover just revealed
the Rinnegan and what's more this
Rinnegan or I guess I should call it
tankin TSU is foreshadowing asta's
ultimate form and power-up the one that
will allow him to stand against God mode
Lucius in the final battle to come this
series is so exciting right now so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our Black Clover videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps me
out a lot and if you are one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos
regularly but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications remember to
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free but it helps me out a lot in a very
direct way finally this video will
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so in the last chapter we
learned that Lucius was about to attain
the Godlike abilities of creation by
combining blood flesh bone and soul
magic once he attains this power he will
be able to alter people's minds and
bodies at will and he will even be able
to create people out of nothing his
ultimate plan is to gain control of all
the magic in the entire world and become
a true God in order to save sister Lily
and everyone else Asta must defeat
Lucius at all costs and that is exactly
what he vows to do but one thing that
struck me about the previous chapter is
the question what if the cost is too
great what if Asta has to make a deal
with the devil or I guess I should say
another deal with the devil in order to
gain the power to defeat Lucius for
example what if he finds himself having
to make a deal with someone like
asteroth or what if he's forced to
overuse his anti-magic to the point that
it goes berserk possibly creating an
all-consuming void that even Asta can't
control what if Asta has to sacrifice
his own soul to win against Lucius the
tropes of making a deal with the devil
and sacrificing your own soul in return
for some power or benefit is very common
in works of fiction and it is possible
that Black Clover could be heading in a
similar Direction with Asta Austin might
have to trade his soul or some other
important part of himself in order to
gain enough power to save everyone by
taking Lucius down but actually I think
that this very chapter has already given
us a huge hint for what asta's ultimate
power up will be a power that will turn
Asta into a dark God a God of
destruction and that is exactly what I
want to talk about in this video because
this chapter could be a lot more
important than most people realize we
pick up with Asta attempting to do what
he promised Lily that he would do first
he's going to defeat the five-headed
dragon and then he will take on Lucius
himself Asta is able to use his
anti-magic zetan to slash off the heads
of the dragon with a single cut which is
of course extremely impressive but
there's a problem despite the fact that
Asta is easily cutting the dragon right
after his attack the head immediately
just heals itself Asta just can't cut
the heads as fast as they can regenerate
and this turn of events could have
serious consequences for Asta as the
final battle against Julius approaches
even though asta's anti-magic is
effectively ripping through the dragon
and its magic powers the creature has so
much magical power that it regenerates
quicker than Asta can destroy it now of
course this Dragon will not be the final
villain in the series and Asta
definitely will find a way to defeat it
probably using some serious teamwork but
this could be some major foreshadowing
about asta's greatest weakness against
Lucius lucius's master plan involves
gaining control of as much magic as
possible first he will combine blood
flesh bone and soul magic within himself
and then he will attempt to control all
the magic in the entire world so if
anyone is going to have enough magic to
overwhelm asta's overpowered anti-magic
it's going to be Lucius if this dragon
can heal faster than austa can attack it
then you better believe that a god mode
Lucius will be able to do the same and
that is where Asta will run into trouble
up to this point anti-magic has always
found a way to overcome every type of
magic that Asta has faced even the
absolutely strongest magic types wielded
by the absolutely strongest opponents
granted Asta often has to rely on
teammates and allies to help him out but
in the end anti-magic usually gets the
job done however this chapter is clearly
reminding us that asta's anti-magic does
have a limit it is not infinite or
all-powerful and this tells us that even
with all his current power and even with
his Newfound Mastery of zetan Asta will
not be able to defeat Lucius at least
not in his current state now am I saying
that Asta is going to lose and Lucius is
going to win in the end of course not
this is a Shonen and Black Clover
definitely follows Shona Norms quite
Faithfully what I'm saying is that in
order to win Asta will need a further
power up he will need to get even
stronger than he is now and yes I know
that he literally just underwent a
training Arc but current Asta is still
not strong enough to defeat god mode
Lucius in order to defeat a God you have
to become a God and pasta is not there
yet so what could asta's next power up
be and why is it Rinnegan I'll get back
to that in a little bit because the
chapter then switches Focus to the
battle between Paladin Heath and yosuga
the strongest of their use and seven
Heath is using an incredible amount of
magic to create a literal Forest of
spiky icicles in an attempt to impale
yosuga this kind of Massive Attack
wouldn't be possible for Heath without
his Paladin powers and Heath is
determined to win because he is fully
committed to lucius's cause of creating
a new righteous world I can't tell if
Heath is brainwashed like sister Lily or
if he's just naturally crazy but knowing
what we know about him before he became
a paladin I wouldn't at all be surprised
if he didn't even require brainwashing
because he's just a fanatic yosuga is
able to avoid Heath's attacks pretty
easily and he doesn't even look like
he's broken a sweat in fact fact yosuga
is smirking as he asks Heath if that's
all he's got as yosuga proclaims that he
will cut down the Paladin for the sake
of the Shogun we get a quick flashback
that teaches us a lot about both yosuga
and ryuya it also reveals the truth
about ryuya's tengensu and why he
doesn't have any magic power growing up
yosuga and ryuya were the strongest
fighters in Hino country and they were
each set to become the leaders of their
respective islands koshu and goshu as
teenagers the two of them had a friendly
rivalry and they would often spar with
each other in order to get even stronger
they were the only people who posed any
sort of real challenge to each other so
it makes sense that they would train
together since no one else could really
test their abilities or force them to
improve then when yosuga was about 17
years old a Great Plague spread through
both koshu and goshu islands and people
were dying in droves those with weak
match power were especially vulnerable
whereas those who had a lot of magic
power were far more resistant the only
way to save the people from this
horrible plague was to obtain the
Legendary Power known as tenginsu and
definitely not known as the Rinnegan the
tengansu is an All-Seeing Eye that will
allow Hino to defeat the plague by
locating the elusive cure but only two
people in the entire country had enough
magic power to obtain this All-Seeing
Eye these two people were of course the
two strongest individuals in the country
ryuya and yosuga but there's a catch to
gaining this legendary ability whoever
chooses to take the tengensu will lose
all of their magic power and Will from
then on be essentially magicless they
will have the power of the tengansu but
no other magic beyond that when he heard
about this price yosuga didn't want
anything to do with the tenginsu sure it
sounded like an extremely useful power
but all his life he wanted to be the
strongest and he loved his current
position and Status he was not willing
to give up his magic power just to
protect the weak when he himself wasn't
even in any danger of dying unlike
yosuga ryuya didn't hesitate he
immediately volunteered to have all his
magic power taken away in return for the
tengansu because he wanted to help the
weak and end the plague as soon as
possible at first yosuga thought that
Ryu was crazy for giving up his power
but he later realized that he himself
was just being selfish while he was
focusing on his own power and on getting
stronger Ryu was focusing on helping
others and because of that the people
loved him and followed him willingly
yosuga always thought that to become
Shogun you have to be the strongest
fighter but thanks to Ryu he realized
that the one who should be Shogun is the
one who cares about the people and who
has the support of the people and so
when it came time time to decide who the
next Shogun will be yosuga supported his
friend Ryu and then he chose to become
the seventh ryuzen back in the present
time Heath can't believe that he still
hasn't been able to take yosuga down
despite the severity of his attacks but
that is only the beginning of Heath's
problems yosuga then reveals the
ultimate nature of his magic iron magic
or iron yojutsu his entire body turns to
Iron and he himself turns into an iron
Soldier he then easily smashes through
Heath's ice and uses his zetan to
absolutely obliterate the Paladin yosuga
declares that he is the strongest there
is and honestly we do have to
acknowledge that his power is truly
impressive Austin defeating a paladin
with anti-magic is one thing we already
know how powerful Asta is and how
overpowered anti-magic is but yosuga's
ability to crush a paladin so
effortlessly is an incredible feat and
also his iron Soldier form is extremely
cool and clearly very strong you better
believe that yosuga will play some role
in the final showdown against Lucius
with the paladins wrecked the only
opponent left here in Hino country is
the five-headed dragon Ryu tells all his
ryuzen that he has been watching their
fights their thoughts and their efforts
and he says that there is no way that
they're going to be defeated it's time
for all of them to take down the
five-headed dragon together and with all
their use and invigorated by ryu's words
everyone prepares to fight alongside
Asta and that is how this hype chapter
comes to an end and while this might
seem like a small chapter that just
gives us a better idea of who yasuga and
Ryu really are I think that this chapter
is foreshadowing some really important
things that we need to pay attention to
First up as I mentioned earlier if this
dragon is producing too much magic for
us that to be able to take down with
anti-magic then we can only imagine how
much bigger that problem will be with
Lucius who is planning to gain control
of all the world's magic Asta will need
something extra to win the final battle
he will need something more and the
answer might be the Rinnegan also known
as the tengansu in this chapter we
learned that in order to gain the power
of tenginsu you need to First give up
all your magic power and accept that
you're gonna be magicalist from now on
so what a lucky coincidence that Asta is
already without magic meaning that he
wouldn't have to sacrifice anything in
order to take on the power of tengensu
and let's be real anti-magic plus
tengansu could be an incredible
combination especially when you consider
the fact that ryuya seems to be able to
predict the future with the tengansu at
least the short term future imagine
Austin on not only having the knowledge
or everything that is currently going on
around him but also having the ability
to predict his opponent's next move
before his opponent even makes it
something like that would certainly give
him the edge that he so desperately
needs in order to take Lucius down that
said is it even possible for Asta to
acquire the tengansu like would ryuya
have to die for Asta to take it or could
he somehow transfer the power onto Asta
at least temporarily there's definitely
a good reason why Tabata is spending so
much time on tengen too and its
backstory so I do think that this
ability will play an important role in
the final battle and hasta May well be
the one to wield it what makes this
potentially even more likely is that
tengen Sue may end up being related to
time magic and asteroth in some way I've
gotten a lot of comments from people who
believe that their use ability to
anticipate the future could be connected
to time Magic and since asteroth is one
of the final remaining mysteries in the
story I wouldn't be surprised if some
link between tengansu and the time devil
existed finally while reading this
chapter I was of course reminded of the
Rinnegan in Naruto in case that wasn't
obvious already and Tabata is clearly
getting a lot of inspiration from Naruto
during this Arc I was especially
reminded of that saying about the
Rinnegan in Naruto as the saying goes in
times of disorder one who wields the
Rinnegan is sent down from the Heavens
to become either a god of creation who
will calm the world or a God of
destruction who will reduce everything
to nothingness Lucius has already been
established as the god of Creation in
the previous chapter with his newly
acquired Powers he will attempt to
become a literal god with the power to
create whatever he wants to from thin
air a god of creation and if is the god
of creation then his final opponent Asta
is the God of destruction that is what
we can expect from the final battle God
of creation Lucius with an incredible
amount of magic at his disposal versus
God of destruction hosta with anti-magic
and maybe the All-Seeing Eye by his side
this will definitely be a final battle
to remember and I can't wait to see how
it all plays out what do you guys think
will Asta Acquire The Power of tenginsu
or will he attain some other power up
before the final battle against Lucius
don't forget to drop me a line down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more Black
Clover content on the channel leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it helps me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos regularly but haven't
subscribed do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys